well we were just speaking to new
Griffith about Remembrance Sunday there
and some his Labour's plans to help
veterans and to muck event today we had
the chance to you sit down this week for
a rare interview with the chief and the
defense staff Senate Carter I was in
Grumman's Bay at the time so my
colleague asked a bunghole our defense
and security correspondent went along
and with the NATO summit to be held in
London next month he began the interview
by asking Gemma caster about the
importance of NATO I think in many ways
it's never been as important in its 70
years of its life because the threats
are very diverse now we talk a lot about
Russia but of course what we also need
to be conscious of is that there are
threats to NATO's southern flank from
the way Africa is evolving from
migration and of course from terrorism
as well so this year we signed off a new
NATO military strategy the first time
since 1967 and that's a strategy that
does try and take a 360 degree look at
the problems that Europe has to confront
in security terms so I think in terms of
the Alliance it's probably as important
as it's ever been
do you think it's being undermined at
the edges whether that's through a u.s.
president who criticizes member states
for not spending enough whether it's
turkey for buying Russian equipment for
example now Adair thinks I think there
are always tensions in alliances it's
the same as a marriage and the plain
fact is with 29 nations it's very
important that we all come together and
we all contribute to that alliance in a
fair way so I think it's right that
burden-sharing is on the agenda and that
people aspire to spend the two percent
of their GDP and the 20 percent of that
on their equipment that was signed up to
in Wales in 2014 let me read you a quote
from that precise moment Wales 2014 come
the end of the Cold War in 1990 that
should have been the time for NATO to
shut up shop give up go home and go away
well of course we all had a huge amount
of optimism in 1989 as the wall came
down and we've celebrating that of
course over the last couple of weeks but
the reality is that the world has
changed it's moved on we now have what I
think would be characterized as global
competition between great powers
something that we probably haven't seen
of this ilk since the middle and the
early part of the last century
so I think NATO's relevance is now back
where it was during the Cold War because
of the nature of that threat in that
evolving global strategic context the
quote I read you is said by Jeremy
Corbyn it could be Prime Minister in a
few weeks time presumably you therefore
entirely disagree with his opinion on
NATO well you wouldn't expect me during
an election campaign to make any
observations about politics at all my
job is to provide a military advice to
whoever will be the leader of the day
entirely however if you feel that he in
any way jeopardize the national security
of this country I would perhaps expect
you to make that clear as people go to
the polls my job is to serve whoever is
the leader of the day and to provide the
appropriate military advice when they
ask me to do that but I've asked you
about NATO in your support of NATO and
you clearly have a very different view
on NATO to Jeremy Corbyn I don't know
it's a straight answer but my view as a
military adviser to any leader of this
country is that NATO remains a very
important part of our national security
and it's right and proper that we should
lean into NATO in every way possible can
I ask you about the IOC's report into
Russian interference I ask you only
because you sit on the National Security
Council I mean do you have an opinion on
whether or not that should have been
released given that it was cleared by
the intelligence agencies no because
once again this is a political question
and it's the choice of the prime
minister as to whether he published this
report at the moment the reports that I
understand is still going through a
process and I have not yet seen it
myself that's then turned to the map
behind you d-day this year we mark the
70th anniversary of that event it was a
opportune moment to remember the
selflessness and the heroism of those
who went across to northern France on
that moment yes certainly and of course
some that's why remembrance matters to
us as well and I think quite
anniversaries like d-day do for us is
they provide us with an opportunity to
educate people because I think it is the
fact these days that fewer people
probably study history or certainly no
history and on the back of that I think
anniversaries are a chance to bring some
of that to life and of course what's
interesting about d-day is we always
think rightly I'm sure about the bravery
of those who stormed the beaches and to
enable the operation from the sea
from the air but actually the
interesting thing about d-day was really
it was a national enterprise it was an
enterprise where you know most of
society got behind it and scientists
businessman railway engineers people who
understood programming and that sort of
detail all came together to provide some
really quite ingenious solutions to what
were really quite difficult problems to
solve and that notion of a national
enterprise I think he's relevant to some
of the problems and challenges that we
have today and certainly in terms of how
our armed forces need to be supported
and what we need to do as we modernize
definitely requires us to think hard
about how we mobilize the effort not
just at the private sector but of
society as a whole do you think it's a
national characteristic that we are
lacking at the moment I wouldn't say
that I think we're living through a
period of phenomenal change at the
moment it's changed it is probably more
more enormous than even the two world
wars combined
and it's also the pace of it is is
increasing rapidly
and on the basis of that I think we do
need to think pretty hard about how as a
nation we're going to manage that change
and it matters to our armed forces
hugely is there a lesson though is there
anything we can take from those those
men and women who performed such heroic
actions in order to liberate Europe on
that day well and I think the lesson
I've taken from it is that we need to
avail ourselves of all of the skills in
art and talent in our society in order
to deal with today's problems and that
requires I think a much more integrated
approach across all of our national
effort how would you assess the British
approach to the UM forces at the moment
given where we are in terms of our
engagement around the world well I can't
remember time in certainly in my
lifetime when the Armed Forces were more
popular and we polled a parent or an
approval rating of gusting 90 percent
last year I think the risk of course
there with the unpopular campaigns in
the last 10 to 15 years is that that
popularity can often be based on
sympathy and not on empathy and of
course our veterans and our armed forces
they don't want to be pitied because
they serve what they actually want is
they want to be respected so I think in
terms of our relationship with society
we very much like it to be based upon
respect and I think a lot of
understand that but I get back to my
point about education it's important
that we continue to educate people on
that the risk of drugging you again into
politics the armed forces have global
projection what role could you therefore
play in a post brexit world in order to
try and fulfill government's agenda of
having a global Britain well I think I
think we need to have a conversation as
a nation about what sort of nation we
want to be in the future and of course
what the Armed Forces offer in support
of our foreign security policy is the
ability to have a presence globally and
we do that in all sorts of ways I mean
at the moment it may surprise people to
know that we've had people in some 65
different countries this year either
providing training or indeed operational
input to what's occurring we do that
through our Navy of course which is its
most obvious in body meant of global but
we also do it through our Air Force and
also through our army so there's a great
deal that we can do globally in order to
be able to promote our values promote
our influence and to project image and
indeed to promote our prosperity and I
think the Armed Forces is an
extraordinarily good way of achieving
that because the values that we espouse
are the values that many of our allies
also wish to espouse tuefel defend stuff
thank you very much
Thanks